[Music]
thanks for being here thanks for having
me sir how you doing I'm doing great you
know great well thank you welcome I need
to hear that every morning you know I
need you yelling at me this in the
morning you look great Conan yeah it's
very motivational I'm gonna be your
alarm clock yeah I'm gonna come to your
house in the morning and just look you
out of your eyes so you look great
some people need right yeah you need to
hear it more yes I do need to hear it
more you look great thank you Kevin
do you ever encounter people you're like
you look I tell them I don't swallow
think I don't like the way you look
really you tell people that I've told
them that in the past yes now I'm sure
it's not something because you you've
said recently I think to a journalist
you said it's hard for you
speaking of yourself who not you said
it's hard for you not to look amazing
that's very true it's very and I will
say I you look fantastic it's like
honestly looks like somebody drew me
it's like perfect
I was like a sketch you look like the
sketch right yeah a great artist sat
down and drew and then here you are this
is what I am I'm a sex symbol it's hard
it's hard it's very hard for me like
mornings aren't tough like you know some
people get up and they're like oh God
let me get myself together I'm together
you're instantly together if you wake up
okay paint a picture for us here you
wake up sometimes I don't need clothes
I've attempted to literally walk out
naked it's perfect like we let us see it
I swear it's unbelievable like I wanna
read a lot though cuz my girl she's like
don't let the world see I'm like selfish
you think she's trying to hide your
perfection yeah yes honestly I feel like
everybody should look like me yeah
what's the feature of yours that you're
most proud of you cast your cabs my
casts are incredible like I came to
describe them it looks like two turkey
legs like this in a good way like the
like the good part like yeah those apart
yeah that like those big turkey leg yeah
that's my cash
okay and you just do you even know why
you have such amazing calves no God did
it yeah it's almost like your curse the
way that was like oh god why I don't
want to be perfect you've yelled at you
just say that to God several times all
the complaints that God is getting from
people and that's your complaint mine
yeah peace my abs one day those ladies
like your calves so amazing that was
like talk to you later
you know what I can't I can't believe I
cannot believe because you have such a
great your voice is so much a part of
your comedy I've used more so than most
communities you got such a great voice
you got such great timing you lost your
voice recently you got laryngitis how
did you how did how could you do
anything without your voice you know
what's funny well I mean you know your
voice is important but you don't know
how important it is until you lose it
because you can't really communicate and
everything comes off rude right yeah you
just look rude like when you're talking
to people
[Laughter]
it's like I look true yeah but I was
such a jackass yeah why are you talking
to me you know I gotta say you are being
a little rude there you're doing that's
what you do it's like well you don't get
your point across you get more
frustrating as time goes on right it's
not so simple it's like the remote
control yeah so simple at first sight
[Applause]
first of all I used to be in a singing
group that's what you do oh yeah yeah
it's gonna miss every day it's what
black people do in a move